today we have a 3.9 nearly 4 gigawatts
of wind energy on the system in the
National Grids control room they are
facing huge challenges as the UK moves
away from fossil fuels in particular too
many renewable energy projects are
waiting too long to connect to the grid
stuck in an old-fashioned queuing system
this has to change says the system
operator promising that stalled energy
projects getting in the way will have to
make progress or give up their place in
the line I think we're trying to Grant
the issue by underscough for the net to
say absolutely we've got to uh you know
for the interest of Britain Britain both
in terms of decarbonization and climate
change but also in terms of energy
security we think we need these reforms
in place and we need people to sort of
look at it really really seriously and
move really really quickly we haven't
got time now to wait around
it is a critical situation as more
people switch to electric cars and heat
pumps for homes demand for electricity
could double by 2035. at the moment
there are over 200 projects due to
connect to the Grid in the coming years
but only half of them even have planning
permission to begin building that
backlog means that projects applying to
connect to the grid today are being told
they're going to have to wait until the
next decade to do so
that includes some of Peter kavanagh's
facilities he runs a company that
develops solar wind and battery storage
and says modernization can't come soon
enough a lot more needs to be invested
in the networks because we've moved from
a centralized power system to a much
more decentralized power system so
that's going from having very large
power stations on the grid to having
multiple smaller generators on the grid
and you know the grid needs to move to
enable that and experts warn whoever's
in power must keep up with the dizzying
pace of change Net Zero is a massive
Economic Opportunity there's Global
competition for the companies that we
have in the UK and the Technologies we
have in the UK and if they don't sort
this out this government and the next
government will suffer economically for
not having done it because we'll lose
the investment and we'll lose the
Technologies of the future
high stakes as the complicated
transition to clean power continues
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News